we're looking at some graphs graphs are
really important tool to wrap your head
around they take some time because it's
a whole different kind of mathematical
thinking from what you've been dealing
with before it's not so much about
symbols and moving them around like an
algebra it's about drawing pictures so
it's a whole new skill set to develop
let's start with number one okay here's
the graph and something might thought oh
is there supposed to be a two up here to
make it x squared I left it
intentionally like this number one so
it's a bit easier for you to start off
but also all of these different families
of graphs you will learn how to draw and
these are two really important ones okay
y equals x minus 2 we've got it here
drawn in and label very helpfully as
this straight line here okay what I want
you to compare it to which by the way do
we agree looks good what I want you to
compare it to is what would the line y
equals x look like what would it look
like hmm
now I'm going to draw it you don't have
to draw it because your graph might get
a little bit busy maybe it's already got
three graphs on it but I do want you to
notice how I draw it just watch
carefully here is what y equals x would
look like okay now I want you to really
carefully compare it to the graph that
leaves your y equals x minus 2 what
things are similar there's lots of
things I said okay no one a bit diagonal
okay but they're not just diagonal like
this slide is diagonal too and this line
is diagonal
they're not just diagonal what else can
you say right they're exactly parallel
right so they're great into the same
very good Shh those things are the same
what's different so only really
primarily one thing that's different
it's moved around okay it's moved around
so you can describe this in a couple of
different ways number one you could say
it's moved downwards can you see that
see how it's sort of gone like that
that's not the only way you could
describe the movement how else could you
describe the shift that's happened it's
not just gone down it's also gone can
you see it's gone to the right just a
little bit how far
two units it's not a coincidence right
that means go to the right two units
okay it's attached to this X which is a
horizontal thing X is the horizontal
axis right okay so far so good
I tell a look at this guy okay now your
graph should look a lot like the blue
graph that we have drawn in here for y
equals x squared minus one it should
look a lot like that can someone tell me
something that's right about that graph
I can see at least two things that are
right what's the name of the shape say
it again I did here it's a parabola okay
so it sums up that's one of a big
difference between one and two so the
parabola is good what else is accurate
about this parabola yeah yeah it's gone
down right we know what the regular y
equals x squared looks like and maybe
you want to draw this just on the side
here we've drawn this heaps of times
this has been tended to this by moving
it down and that's correct we are
supposed to move down okay but there's
something that's going on doodle the
rides very close but it's not quite
right Jake engineer okay so we were
supposed to move down one this guy has
moved down kisi so it's gone a little
bit far okay we've got the basic essence
there though so we can pick this up this
should actually be it's very close this
shape like that okay and the inter sets
are negative 1 negative 1 and 1 ok it's
very very close a lot of it's right can
I also point out and it is a bit
trickier doing it on the whiteboard
excuse me there's a difference apart
from the position between my orange
graph in the blue graph how would you
describe it look at the picture quite
closely what else is different between
them apart from up-and-down now I can
see people sort of moving their hands
and what would you how would you
describe it verbally okay so these are
use here they've also changed when you
move it up do you see these also they
sort of move inwards
do you notice that and if I move it far
enough you don't get x-intercepts at all
like look at this guy
see that if I went x squared plus like a
hundred every too far away or wouldn't
never touch one for more thing I want to
highlight see how this part of the graph
it looks good and it keeps on going
further up and up and up and up but do
you see this one does something sort of
different you notice it sort of goes
just kind of leans back in this way okay
this is a very easy to state to me I
want you to look carefully at your graph
as well what we're looking for here is
in suffer than s the symmetry of this
graph it's very very important I was
asking for that um it's symmetrical can
you have a look at your graph please and
please make sure that in all parts of
you've drawn it's symmetrical if we
drawn a little bit less it would have
looked a bit better right it's pretty
hard to do it for anyone to get it
exactly bang on perfectly so that's why
I always draw my graphs in pencil and I
encourage you to do the same because
it's very easy to get it wrong the first
okay all right so let me get rid of this
one and we've got our fixed up version
in there okay now excuse me this one
here this is a bit trickier okay so does
anyone want to describe for me I should
have put this down does anyone describe
for me see how there's a plus one in
there what did that do what is that to
someone who has a I've had a lot of
great contributions so far at this side
of the room so I want to know I've got
much from the right-hand side of the
room can someone tell me what the plus
one does anyone any takers
yeah Nathan when you record ok this
movement right there is a there is a
slide or a translation that's I think
what we mean we'll say boo okay it's a
bit tricky see it is minus one it moved
you down so therefore plus one it's not
that illogical to think it moves up
however I'm going to think back to this
question and this is why I highlighted
this right this one actually moves to
the which directions SEO mijin it moves
to the right to remember that the reason
why it moves to the right it's about
left-right not about up and down is
because the two is next to our
and X and X is which access it's the
horizontal it's the left-right axis do
you notice that okay so therefore here
see how the plus one so the next to an X
so it's also doing something left right
that's a bit weird okay that's the first
thing I want to point out is it left or
is it right
hmm we traded this one guy so this is a
bit funny it's sort of backwards right
we're used to thinking of negatives as
left but when we graphed it it obviously
went to the right so if this negative
number means right then this guy means
left can you write that down for me
underneath when you've written the
question write down left one unit agree
you had your hand up
if you want you can plot some points to
convince yourself when you put in X
equals 2 into this guy Y will equal 2
minus 2 which is 0 so that's 2 comma 0
that's moves to the right hasn't it from
0 0 is where you would expect it to be
ok so and you can you can put in x
equals 3 and x equals 4 etc and you'll
just get a bunch of points and they're
all moved over to the right Leo got it
right the first time everything has
moved off ok very good
we know this thing is going to move to
the left so I will draw a parabola but
it's going to be a bit more on this side
than on that side okay what about this
number did you do your exercises
yesterday and work out what that number
does does something different I'll give
you a tip it doesn't move it left or
right or up and down what does it do
yeah Jennifer yeah very good do you
remember we actually experimented on do
you remember we drew that on desmos and
we slid it around remember that so this
guy here means it's more narrow narrow
is a good word right or you could say
it's more steep ok so I'm going to draw
it for you and then we're going to work
out exactly where it goes what color
blue hasn't been used yet right yeah ok
so it's gone to the left one unit right
we know where parabolas usually are
what's that really important point at
the bottom of the course part of a V the
vertex so the vertex is usually right
there in the middle but you told me to
move it over to the left one unit so
here it is to the left one unit ok I can
see how steep these are so I'm going to
make mine steeper I think it's going to
look something like this that's steeper
the new original problem reasonably ok
now I want to know where are the
important spots on this you remember we
wrote down this is negative 2 and this
is 2 the intercepts are important so how
do I work out intercepts we already know
how to do this already ok I know where
that is so what what was the coordinates
again
well what's the number sorry I should
say minus one very good negative one
okay so that's good
what about this guy I mean I'm
suggesting it's there Brian very
hopefully put a scale in here but how do
I go is actually there if I got it right
how I work this out I'm gonna have to
put something in think about this you
might like to jot this down to find the
this guy's the x-intercept because on
the x-axis so what's this guy called
y-intercept to find the y-intercept yeah
you remember let X equal zero so here's
the equation so I'm going to go y equals
to two what's going to go in here zero
plus one very good and I square 0 plus 1
is 1 1 squared is 1
ok so there you go so more than just a
pretty face I did actually know that it
was 2 so that's the corner right there
and you're done
ok